nah believe me i'll take all the help i
can get chris evans appeared to have
accidentally shared a pic of his um
man business with his six million
instagram followers
and naturally fans lost their damn minds
crazy i get it i get it i get it now the
likes of mark ruffalo
chrissy teigen and even chris's own
brother
yes his brother are weighing in on his
since deleted not safe for work post
here's what went down on saturday chris
posted a clip of his fam playing heads
up on his insta story
but when that sweet home video ended a
camera roll popped up on screen which
appeared to show a pic of chris
fully exposed now it's unclear if the
camera roll belonged to the 39 year old
star
or not since he has yet to address the
slip up publicly
but that didn't stop the moment from
trending on twitter
you never know what's gonna happen
oh look he's learning wow
that's when mark ruffalo attempted to
console his avengers co-star
tweeting quote bro while trump is in
office there is
nothing you could possibly do to
embarrass yourself
see silver lining here's me guys
and while chrissy teigen didn't call out
chris specifically
she shared a relatable story of her own
writing quote
my whatsapp automatically saves every
photo to my role so any boobs in my
phone are my girlfriends showing me
their boobs or boobs they hate
or boobs they love or yeah deaf also my
boobs i'd say 80 percent of my role is
whatsapp nonsense between friends
and then chris's younger brother scott
evans chimed in
on sunday tweeting was off social media
for the day yesterday
so what'd i miss stick with et for our
continuing coverage on this
you know to see if chris addresses the
lack of coverage
in that photo i'm not touching it i'm
not touching it
you